this is a production of Cornell
University
basically
going to kind of give you a tour of some
of the things that we've done for the
climate Center try to relate them back
to Agriculture and and things where
where there might be some interest in
the types of things that you guys do so
if I can get my slides to advance which
they're not doing right off top here
all right so first off what's the
climate Center what's the Northeast
climate Center we're one of six of these
centers that exist across the country
um we've been here at Cornell for a long
time actually kind of an antidote when I
was a grad student you can kind of
figure out way back when at Rutgers
actually the climate Center funded my
research so kind of came full circle
um but the idea here behind the climate
Center is Noah collects a lot of data
they have a lot of weather forecasts in
the idea why Noah pays us to do what we
do is how can we take their data and
make it the most useful to people so
kind of our little
tagline there is taking data and turning
it into information we do that in a
number of ways
so kind of the first I'm going to call
it kind of case study that I'm going to
talk about should be very familiar to
Harold because it actually goes back to
the work that uh Harold and I did back
in the adapt end days when we were here
in Bradfield and really
um what the main focus of that work was
was to create a high resolution data set
so we it was an integral part of adapt n
but it is also an integral part of kind
of what we do day to day in a number of
different applications so really the the
idea here is the the red dots there
which I think got moved around on my map
are where weather stations are so if I
just look at New York State there's
probably about 200 250 weather stations
that report each day okay and obviously
there's a lot that goes on in between
them so our kind of classic problem is
how do we take the data that are
collected at these stations at these red
dots and figure out what it does in your
field or my field or something like that
not if I'm a research field but if I'm a
grower or something like like that and
there's really no lack of solutions to
this right most of it is is statistical
you can create you can do uh different
types of of spatial weighting and things
like that you can go into machine
learning
um you know basically the one method
that's used quite extensively in our
field is this regression based
interpolation the acronym for the data
set is called prism and it's it's about
a four kilometer grid across the country
um would have been very useful for us
but our one problem is it takes time to
process these data so like prism is not
available until like about two days from
now and if I'm a grower and I need to
make a decision today or tomorrow
kind of need the information today or
tomorrow so we kind of developed this
method as a way of kind of getting a
jump on things
so really what do we do for temperature
we use short-term weather forecasts as
kind of our data set but then we take
these stations and we use that to ground
truth the red weather or forecast so the
forecast is on a very fine grid it knows
about the Finger Lakes it knows about
the topography it knows whether the soil
is wet or dry and things like that so it
really brings in a lot of physical
parameters but I think we all know here
our weather forecast isn't 100 accurate
close but not quite
um so we then bring in the observations
to kind of hold that weather forecast
um accurate you know kind of hold it as
ground truth and then use that bias as a
way of adjusting the forecast
for rainfall we do the same thing but
with radar right we all can go on our
app and see you know it's raining and
figure out how much it rained from the
app but again there's some problems with
the radar it's not 100 accurate so we
use the the gauges to keep it honest
um
so I think I pretty much said all of
that so
fun so really how does this work so if
I'm looking at the forecast model that
we're using for temperature
um you know there's a whole slew a whole
range of observations that would come in
you know if if I'm making this forecast
I bring them in it could be satellites
weather balloons could be radar it could
be observations
um you know so any number of things come
into this observations and in in our
lingo what's called there's a process
that's called Data assimilation kind of
bringing in all these desperate
disparate sources of information kind of
correcting further biases and
peculiarities and eventually what
happens there is we get an analysis and
what the analysis is is nothing more
than the starting point of the weather
forecast right weather forecasts are big
complex mathematical models and they
need to start from some place so this
analysis is kind of a snapshot of what
it is to start this forecast
um and then that goes into the model and
the model comes out and makes the
forecast right so that's kind of the
thing the one other piece of this is
then actually the forecast
gets fed back into the data analysis
right so if I'm this model that we use
is an hourly model it forecasts every
hour so the forecast I made last hour or
two hours ago or even three hours ago
isn't that far off and that provides
some information
um and it's basically this forecast that
we're using to guide our interpolation
between the stations I should also you
know I did also mention all of the
things that come in to the forecast
model in terms of the landscape in the
hydrology and in addition to the
meteorology
um the grid density of these models is
for really using a 25 kilometer grid now
on the land surface
um one of the key things we do is you
think of each of these the circles with
the TGs in them
as a grid in the model we want to
compute a bias we want to know how far
off the model is from the station
so we have to do or one of what the
first thing we have to do is get this
station which might be at a different
elevation and might be at a different
spot
coincident with the station right I know
what the temperature here is at the
station I want to see what is the
difference from the grid
so we do two things the first thing is
to bring this grid Point down to the
same elevation as the station so we
correct for elevation and a nice thing
about using a meteorological model is
it's not just flat on the land but it
also tells us what's going on up
vertically in the atmosphere so we can
use the model's lapse rate that's what
I'm showing here is this blue line how
temperature varies in the atmosphere on
this particular day for this particular
hour to bring this grid point back down
to the station elevations kind of a a
double duty kind of interpolation so to
speak this kind of physical
interpolation to account for elevation
and then a statistical interpolation to
account for how far off we are from the
station
um so again that spatial interpolation
uh kind of used two different methods
really the first method we use to go
from grids to stations is a spline based
method multiple multi quadrant we look
for a radius of influence around the
station so my x's here are stations so I
bring in a lot of grid points around
that station
um you know this this circle this radius
of influence kind of some sensitivity
analysis to see you know once you get
Beyond about
0.8.9 kilometers in radius it doesn't
really matter in this example here for
Syracuse
um so these are you know this station
this grid Point here is is weighted
heavier than this point here but all of
these influence the interpolation
and then uh once we do that at each of
the station locations we have a bias so
this would be an example of the bias
deal that we've interpolated to the
stations each day and these are in these
are in K or degree C so you know you can
see in these blue and purple areas about
a degree a degree and a half low
um you know maybe about you know two two
and a half degrees in some spots so um
the bias field comes into play here at
each of the stations and then this is
interpolated back to the grid points to
adjust them uh based on the station and
that gives us a nice I think my last one
oh nope one other thing
um we're working in this model at 20
kilometers we'd really like to have a
finer resolution
so what we do in that case is um from
the bias field that we've computed uh we
go back to the uh model grid points and
now instead of interpolating them
vertically and horizontally
um to the stations we do that to a uh a
five kilometer
digital elevation model so we're
choosing this kind of elevation in the
landscape as being analogous to stations
we're interpolating the model to those
and then we take that bias field that we
uh computed and bring that back to this
five kilometer grid now so the same type
of process but uh with a different grid
spacing there and again the five
kilometer digital elevation model is
being adjusted based on the model uh
lapse rates
so this would be an example of kind of
what we get at the end we just use the
observations and did some kind of
inverse distance weighting or something
to Contour it on this day we'd have a
pattern that looks like that and if your
eyes aren't very good which they
probably aren't and I don't know where
the pointer went
okay it is
um that's the southern shore of Lake
Ontario so we're probably about right
here in this in this pattern and if you
come here I think if you squint your
eyes and kind of maybe turning your head
a little bit you kind of see the Finger
Lakes in there so the temperature
pattern of the Finger Lakes showing up
on this day is being a little bit warmer
it's a March day
um than the surrounding landscape so you
get a kind of a feel for how we can get
more of the spatial detail and
temperature
precipitation we do the same thing more
or less it's with radar
um it's already on a four kilometer grid
so when we get data from the radar it's
on a four kilometer grid each pixel is
four kilometers Square
um we find those pixels that overlap our
code co-located with a rain gauge
compute the bias and then just inverse
distance weight that bias back to each
of the grid points and
we get a precipitation map so again this
is just station data
and here's some more fine scale detail
uh when we're using the radar data so
maybe if you key in on this area here in
eastern Pennsylvania where the rainfall
totals were kind of over a hundred
millimeters in this kind of purple ish
bluish area here and you really have no
you know no no trace of that in the with
just using the observation so these high
totals missed all of the rain gauges
um we kind of look at some validation
statistics
um lots of numbers but the the reds are
the best and basically the nrcc is us so
it's good to see a lot of the Reds in
our column across either winter or
summer and over a range of precipitation
amounts in millimeters only the low
amounts in the summertime does the radar
itself do better so the rate we can get
these estimates from radar but the radar
has bias in it it you know especially
maybe on a day like this when there's
freezing the the snowflakes reflect
differently than the raindrops and if
they're melting it it really messes
things up
um so how do we use this uh so this is a
web app that we have called climate
smart farming
um basically the first thing you would
do is come in and be presented with a
map then you can drop a pin someplace
and I could have picked Ithaca but I
guess I picked some place in The
Boondocks of Cortland County to kind of
maybe show a point
um so I click there and uh what this
tool does is look at Degree Days
and um our gridded data set that we've
done we've actually done it
retroactively so we have over 30 years
of this type of temperature grid for the
landscape so um not a very good not a
very useful example at least in real
time since I did it for this year
um right but the way the tool would work
is the green line would show the
accumulation of Degree Days season to
date at that point based on our data set
the little red nib there at the end is a
forecast of degree days out for the next
five days from a forecast model
um not not the same one we use but
basically a Weather Service forecast and
then kind of all of the neat I think
climatological data relies here so
basically we have this kind of gray band
and what that is is the period of record
range from our data set so for this grid
point in Cortland County New York
um you know pick your favorite date the
Fourth of July and the most degree days
that ever accumulated there were a
little over 800 the least were a little
low under 500. uh the two lines blue and
purple represent a 15 in blue and a
30-year average the last 15 and 30 years
um anything strike anybody about that 15
and 30 year average
yeah the 15-year average is higher why
is that
something called climate change maybe
right so I mean this is a key of this
tool to say hey for some reason as
climatologists we always use the 30-year
average and the 30-year average ain't
the right thing to use anymore basically
a 15-year average is a better way of
looking at things and I think this
demonstrates that quite closely that you
know you might be here the end of
September and yeah in the 30-year
average expecting about 2 000 and you're
really up around 22 or 2 400.
um so that's that and then all of these
bars here
um represent the first and last frost
dates all right so the idea of if we're
using this tool to figure out planting
or something like that I want to know
well when when should I really be
planting I can change my planning date
to basically minimize my corn getting
Zapped by Frost in the spring again the
light blue lines are the period of
record and the darker blue lines of the
last 15 years so again you can kind of
see maybe the darker blue lines or to
that part of the graph again bringing in
that idea of climate change
and then so that can be used for
planting in the spring but really what a
lot of people use this tool for is is
looking here at the end of the season
and saying boy I'm really going kind of
slow am I ever going to get enough
Degree Days to meet maturity or do what
I have to do again I'm not the
agronomist
um before I have a risk of frost okay so
kind of right here a nice climatology of
the growing season kind of at a push of
a button
um we also do something similar for a
fall cover crops again based on the
climatology so
um this is is buckwheat
and basically here
um it says um it basically goes from any
day you know this is all climatology
nothing uh nothing for our current
growing season here but basically it
says based on the climatology again
15-year
um 30 year and period of record so
15-year 30-year period of record again
you see that climate change in there
they're they're nice and and spread
apart if I planted my buckwheat as a
cover crop on say August 13th
it would have a 30 uh 73 probability
chance of maturing before the last frost
basically is the way that would work you
can kind of see in which years you made
it to that threshold of degree days that
you would need uh in the blue and not in
the red any questions on that
so the other thing going to shift gears
um the other thing we do is work a lot
with weather stations and we do this
actually most use with the integrated
Pest Management program in New York uh a
group called Nua
newa.cornell.edu mainly fruit crops
um
kind of
it even though it's New York IPM it has
a pretty wide footprint
um you know New York New England down
into New Jersey down into the Carolinas
out to Minnesota I think there's about a
handful of stations in Utah
um some in Nebraska so it's it's a
widespread Network all of very similar
weather stations and that's important
because that allows us to grab the
weather we don't have to go to you and
grab the data from your weather station
and Tony and grab his it's kind of all
um more or less consistent
hey
um
we basically just did a lot of web
development work on it to make it mobile
responsive to clean up the design to
make it customizable
um you can come in and say hey remember
where I am remember when I planted my
stuff so you don't have to enter in all
those parameters each time
um I guess I did want to say I want to
point out even though it's mostly fruit
um the the new person that's directing
Nua has really been expanding to field
crops as well so I think that's
something you'll see coming into play
and the way we've designed this in both
the the software and the coding is for
it to be really really Nimble so if
something comes up quickly and it's
really just no it's degree day based or
uses the data that we can have we can
Journey we can gin up and turn out a new
model pretty quickly so a good example
of that is c chord maggot and again I'm
not the I'm not the agronomist but I
guess New York is basically looking to
Outlaw or band a certain chemical that's
used to treat Seed corn and so this is
this is something that they developed
with us in in response to that
um so a lot of data flow and our data
system is called Asus so basically what
this is saying is kind of looking at the
data system right we have data coming in
from a number of disparate sources right
the newest stations which are uh Kestrel
instruments
um another group of instruments that are
on set so uh basically those are coming
in uh Weather Service data our own data
from from our Farms here
um we bring in data from a Statewide
Network in Michigan another Statewide
Network in Delaware so again a number of
different networks but with the key
thing I'm not going to individual
Growers and getting their data right The
Growers have to kind of buy and say yep
I'm going to get this kind of weather
station and that data all goes to a
central point
um
and then basically the way it works is
that data is stored in our repository
um we're basically an operational
place so I can't afford to have my
servers go down one day in the middle of
the growing season like when the Apple
farmers are looking to spray for fire
blight or something like that so I have
a number of redundant repositories uh
basically we're doing this all on the
cloud now with um load sharing and
things like that so if a work bus comes
in and it tries to hit the server here
and we're down or we're busy it knows
where to go to look for another server
on AWS we used to do this with our own
kind of hardware and things like that
and we still have one set of servers
that are but increasingly it's all on
the cloud
um and then through the power of you
know the web service that Asus is the
data can then be queried by these
centralized models and and spit out
something for a user so yeah a bad slide
again but again just to give you an idea
of how our data system works
um basically a lot of code here but the
thing to boil down is I'm making this
this is really if we focus in on here
I'm making the request I'm picking a
station I happen to pick Minneapolis for
some reason a date range and I'm saying
Hey I want to know minimum temperature
and I want to know basically
um the last date
in a year that it got to 28 degrees all
right so Frost application so I'm kind
of setting it up you know a bunch of
code here but obviously I want Min
temperature I want the last date it's
less than or equal to 28. I want to tell
me the day so that's what that add value
is
um so I set up this this set of
parameters I make a request to the
server and within milliseconds it'll
spit back the results for this looks
like I'm asking for at least uh what a
10-year or so period that in 1992
um you know on 6 30
or no from in 1992 the last temperature
below 28 was actually a 17 in April
um 27 in April and you can go down so a
very quick query of not just the data
but the information right I'm not asking
for minimum temperatures I want to know
when the Foster
um we can do this with our gridded data
so same type of thing I've asked for um
I'm in Vermont and I want to know in
each County in each year what was the
coldest minimum temperature
um so again all those grids it knows
where the counties are and we can get
that response back in this case I think
I just asked for a single year
um so actually a single day leap day
um so a minus 24 in that county a minus
26 in that county you get the idea
um it can also do our mapping directly
so
um and so the way this has worked we use
it for Nua but it's out there and freely
available this is a group at Purdue that
has a very similar degree day calculator
we have nothing to do with it other than
our API is open for them to grab the
data so we're providing the operational
feed for somebody else's model
um what we'd really like to do is you
know it it'd be nice if there could be a
bunch of different products and really
what our system does gives you data in
different formats so you don't right now
if you're using it you you have to be
kind of say Yep this is the way art
gives me the data back it's standardized
and and you can you know you basically
have to deal with this but if you have
your own model that you want to do
something else maybe you've developed it
in-house and you're expecting data to
come in in one way but you want to use
it in the next state it'd be nice to be
able to kind of uh format our data to be
used in a different application
um you know this system again used in ag
uh The Weather Service uses it
um the USDA uses its uh scan anyone know
about the scan Network in USDA right
that's their soil climate uh Access
Network again their data come into our
database number of different things
um
the other thing we do again this is
another of our models but I want to
focus in on this kind of end period here
what do we do for the forecast right any
of these tools especially where we're
using to make real-time decisions it's
nice to know what's going on today but
everyone wants to know what's going to
happen right they're not going to make a
decision based on what has happened they
want to know what's going to happen in
the next couple of days so we do bring
in a forecast
um so this is a an apple freeze tool
recent data basically these are minimum
temperatures in the forecast and the
kind of yellowy orangey line is at least
right now at what temperature we'd
expect 50 percent of the blossoms to be
killed so so far so good but if it keeps
staying warm we might be in some
problems
um so what do we use we use a Weather
Service product it's a gridded forecast
called the ndfd the national digital
forecast database
um
it's hourly database
um two and a half kilometer resolution
goes out to its hourly to 72 hours but
actually goes out about seven days at
either three hour or six hour resolution
where am I what time am I shooting for
okay
um so
um and the
so that's a that's a ready nice
off-the-shelf product that we can just
grab from the weather service but in
kind of our research application here we
said how about if we ran our own weather
forecasting model
in well I guess it started when we were
in Bradfield but now we're in Snee so in
Snee hall or in roads all around the
clouds could we do better than the
Weather Service does for predicting the
weather in in the areas that we're
looking at so the the uh kind of the the
weather model did your on this Regional
scale is called the The Wharf the
weather research and forecast model
um you know we can run it in-house we
can run it on the cloud we actually do
both
um the neat thing is we can run this
model at whatever spatial resolution we
want so we can do it at 32 kilometers
nine kilometers three kilometers I think
we can even crank it I've seen people
crank it down to less than one kilometer
and
I probably have swamp land in Florida
that I could sell them because I'm not
quite sure that yeah I think you're
really if you can if you can believe one
side of the football field versus the
other side of the football field I'm not
quite sure about that so uh we chose to
use these three spatial resolutions
um
the other thing that um
is kind of the latest in in weather
forecasting is to run the models as an
ensemble all right so not just run the
model once and say Yep this is what the
temperature is going to be but actually
run many simulations of the model they
all basically are starting from the same
initial they can start from the same
initial conditions and perhaps just be
have some differences in how the physics
might be parameterized in the model not
the not the main you know equation of
state and those signs of physics but you
know how do we handle soil moisture in
this one or how do we handle convection
in that one the kinds of things where
you need to parameterize the model a
little bit and I might do it one way and
Harold might do it another way and
somebody else might do it a third way
we're all right there is no right answer
but we've chosen to do things
differently and obviously our models
spit out different answers so that's one
way of getting these ensembles the other
way is to take the initial conditions
and just perturb them a little bit add a
little bit of random error to it right I
really don't know what the initial
conditions are so if I'm off by a little
bit what would that do to my model so in
this case that's what we're doing uh
same model same forecast but I know I
guess it's nine different it looks like
more than that actually each of these
lines these light blue lines is a
realization one of the members of The
Ensemble all right so uh cleverly we
call these spaghetti diagrams do they
look like spaghetti and you can see you
know some of the models if this is
temperature or up here someplace others
are down here uh there's a good cluster
of them here in the middle
the red is The Ensemble median right so
if I just take the average of all of
these but really yeah these all cluster
together and stuff but there's really no
reason to say yeah those are the best I
mean there's there's nothing to say that
they might be all wrong for the right
they all might be wrong for the same
reason but they're still wrong basically
and kind of look at the distribution
it's not all that you know we expect
temperature maybe we'd want it or we're
we're assuming it's nice and normally
distributed but really out here we have
something that's multimodal yeah most of
them fall in here but there's this
several of them are saying it's going to
be cold several of them are saying it's
going to be one so it's basically where
I want to go with this is is after we've
done this Ensemble of forecast WE Post
process process them to get an idea of
what the errors are and then use that
post-processing to adjust the newest
forecast
um so as an example
um if the black line is reality that's
my observation and I have several
Ensemble members here in the blue that's
what they're saying the temperature is
and um you know in this case really just
look at the lines I have the observation
here at somewhere it's between zero and
one degree
um The Ensemble median or mean is
somewhere's here at negative 0.5 so
normally I would say yep I'm gonna make
this as my forecast and I'm going to be
off by that amount but I'm really not
taking into account any of this other
information about The Ensemble spread
um
so a complicated graph but basically how
we do our post processing is right I
need to know the difference between what
it really is and what the model is
saying and obviously I can't do that
today or it isn't much of a forecast
right so we look back 27 days
or 25 days and really get a distribution
of all of these biases and without going
into the statistics I just looked at the
raw Ensemble I get this blue
curve but if I did some kind of uh my
post-processing here in the orange curve
the the best way I can describe it it's
kind of like doing a regression on the
distribution right so I'm changing the
spread I'm changing the I'm altering the
spread I'm altering me and I have now
this new probability distribution that I
can add to the forecast also my forecast
then isn't yep it's going to be 20 oh
it's tomorrow tomorrow's Friday nope
it's going to be 32 tomorrow okay I'm
going to say there's some distribution
of temperature tomorrow right based on
adjusting uh the probability
distribution of adjusting the Ensemble
uh based on its its past bias
um so we did our little study area in
kind of three regions of New York again
we were working with Nua on this so it's
not surprising the fruit reaches in the
Finger Lakes in Lake Erie and out here
on Long Island
um
and a bunch of different results here
and I'll walk you through them actually
pretty quickly
um solar radiation humidity and
temperature
um basically what we're showing here is
the first two bars in the case of solar
radiation are the raw forecast so blue
at three kilometers
Brown at nine kilometers and then the
green and the red are when we take those
forecasts and post-process them we
basically all right we're adjusting them
based on the past bias
um the vertical axis is kind of a skill
measure and we want that measure to be
small okay basically the C there is
cumulative so you can imagine the
cumulative distribution function it's
really what is the observed CDF versus
what we're forecasting right observe
probabilities versus forecast and we
want those to be right on top of one
another so we'd love for that to be zero
okay so the take home message here is
yeah this post-processing the red and
the green make a difference we really
improve our forecast by doing this
post-processing just basically
incorporating in the past bias right
this has nothing to do with it's still a
forecast
um but also the red and the green bars
are pretty much the same bar so we don't
get any benefit to going from nine
kilometer resolution to three kilometer
resolution in this forecast
if we look at specific humidity and
temperature the same type of thing right
so we have raw 3 raw nine post-process
three post process nine so three and
nine don't make a difference
post-processing makes a huge difference
and then over here on this side these
three bars the first bar this big kind
of purple bar with big tails is a model
called the GFS and what that is is
that's the model that we're using to
initialize the work right the work is
just over the Finger Lakes I need to
know what's going on to feed data into
the model so that's the big Global model
so if I just use that
I'd be doing a really crappy job I get a
lot of improvement by running the high
resolution model
and then these two bars at the end are
this ndfd forecast that I get directly
from the Weather Service so that's their
forecast and even here by running our
own model we can do a lot better in
terms of forecasting so the the bottom
line take home message in this is
the ndfd is there kind of okay it's a we
kind of argue it's the same as if we
didn't post process our Ensemble but by
doing The Ensemble run and
post-processing it even at a nine
kilometer resolution uh helps out quite
a bit and you might say three nine
kilometers what's the big deal it's a
lot of big deal in terms of the amount
of computer power that you would need to
run this model
I'm going to skip over that
um
skip over that the very last thing
um one of the other pieces of data that
we have in our database are climate
projections all right so future
projections from climate models and
things like that and I am like my
batteries
um so we've been working with the USDA
actually the the department of the chief
of uh um Economist uh to look at climate
change indicators in agriculture so this
is a big National effort that that we've
been a part of
um our data set our database fits in
there quite a bit so again we're getting
have a number of downscaled climate
model projections in in our database so
here's an example of of a high emission
scenario the downscale data set is Loca
it's an ensemble average from the local
projections so basically saying hey what
is going to be the change in seasonal
Degree Days as we go out to mid-century
so some place here in Ithaca we're
looking like we can gain about 1200
Degree Days in a growing season
um when we can apply this to any number
of things so one of the indicators in
the in the climate indicators report is
actually Frost risk in apples
um Frost risk and fruit crops is more
generic
um so we use the data first to get a
handle on chilling requirements right so
and then on on development so an example
here of actually some observed data for
Apple development from Poughkeepsie over
the last you know 20 30 years so if we
pick on say the full bloom dates here in
red
um back in 1980 it was about May 15th
and if we just kind of scratch our eyes
and come down here we're probably about
May 1st or so so again a week or so
um earlier in the bloom date
and then we can go to the climate model
projections and kind of see the same
thing so if I'm going from 80 but now
out to 2100
um you know this is for a different spot
so this is out in Geneva but you see a
continuation of that Trend in basically
going from about May 7th
um you know almost half a month later
into into April so that's that's a big
deal
um then we can take that and say hmm
what is that going to mean for the risk
of killing an apple blossom right as if
the frost dates are getting later in the
year you might say that might be a good
thing might be good for apples right
um and really again in in the in the end
here
um what we found out is it really
matters where you are okay if you're in
a place and the idea here is that the
black line represents the future the
gray bars and the dotted line represent
the current climate and it's basically
the risk of getting 50 kill in any of
these different stages of development so
if we look at a place like Asheville and
kind of the fruit belt of North Carolina
or Yakima in Washington
um if we're out into the future
basically the black line is always below
the dotted line and actually in most
cases below the confidence interval of
the frost risk in the current climate so
we're saying there the risk of Frost the
risk of frost killing apples is
declining
um if we move up here to Ithaca
um and we do the same thing
um basically what we see is a different
pattern notice now the black line is
above the dotted line and it's still
within the error bars and what did we
just do there I have no idea so the
bottom line is a place like Ithaca
the frost risk doesn't really go down in
the future climate and actually and
maybe not statistically it goes up and
the reason why that is occurring
actually has in Ithaca the risk of
getting killed by a frost if you're an
apple blossom here has more to do with
the variance of the daily weather as
opposed to the average
okay so in all those other places North
Carolina and Washington it's all driven
by what the average temperature is but
here in Ithaca it's driven by what the
variance is so in the Northern and
that's true in other Northern climates
so that was my second to last slide so
basically the idea of this USDA project
is to really make these types of
indicators living you know most of the
indicators report you see it's a nice
PDF on the web and you say yep well we
did this in 2018 and that's where our
data ends we want to make this kind of a
living thing to show those Trends Going
On Through Time and obviously do it with
more we are doing it with more than
Apples there's you know some insect
metrics for insects emergence Degree
Days
so I'll leave it at that
thank you very much we have time for a
few questions
there was one uh maybe there was one
quick question online uh that I could
ask and then after that I will bring the
microphone
um the question was how are the Growing
Degree Days calculated and it was a
matter of uh
asking what was the base yeah um and and
the question there is
tell me what you want it's it's it's
it's it's it's Dynamic you know the the
base is not fixed you can tell the web
service what base you want
um above or below the base if you want
to use 86.50 to have both you can
specify that so it it's designed to be
very
um very customizable
do they count just since the last frost
or will they count before the last frost
um you have to specify a starting date
there is not an option to like have it
pick the last frost sentence as the
starting date
yeah that would be a cool that that
would be doable actually to do
what all right thank you very much for
the nice talk and in the very beginning
you talked about the diet downsizing
from 25 kilometer to five kilometer and
the temperature when you do downscaling
you mentioned about the elapses and uh
so for the downscaling of precipitation
what what do you take into consideration
yeah I I don't have the the radar gives
me precipitation at four kilometers
that's the native resolution of the
radar so that's we don't do any
downscaling with the radar data it's
it's the four right with the models
we're kind of getting the models at 25
kilometers and we are down scaling it to
five kilometers actually four and a half
kilometers but with the radar the radar
is is already giving us that's the
that's the spatial resolution of the
radar beam
thank you for the radar product I should
say
yeah very very interesting um now RCP
8.5 has been widely discredited in the
recent time I mean it's just an
absolutely unrealistic scenario do you
have plans to redo this for more
realistic scenarios we have this yeah
all the I my my ride was just a bad
choice of slides that's fine but my main
question was about uncertainty and I'm
very interested in how you and you're
dealing with uh your clients how do you
get them to understand you seem to be
much better in meteorology than we are
in other fields in in understanding
probabilities risks uncertainties do you
have any specific strategies using these
tools to help them to to train or
understand yeah other than um again with
the with the downscale data we do have
an ensemble of models so there are
actually 32 different runs so you can
get that Ensemble spread in in as much
as looking at that and trying to get
them to understand that
um that's that's basically the way that
it's done right so you know
you have to think about the the
uncertainty in the scenario right we're
making a guess on what we're going to
look like CO2 wise in the future
and then we have the uncertainty in the
models and then actually even now
um the same you know like I used the
weather forecast as an example of
tweaking the initial conditions well now
the climate models initial conditions
are tweaked a little bit so the same
model has an ensemble and really where
that is useful is if you tweak the same
model and get the the uncertainty right
that's that's the natural variation in
the climate right that's the fact that
it's not the same weather every year and
then you can look at the difference
between the models and that's just the
biases and the models so you can start
to drill down on that aspect of things
but it's how they use it for decision
making it it is and boy in anybody that
I've worked with
I have to say that's more of a uh you
know especially with the extreme
rainfall stuff that we've been doing
it's more a political decision than a
than a scientific decision what their
what their level of risk adverseness or
not averseness is and that kind of stuff
yes
I didn't recognize you under the mask
um
I've been talking with with other people
about brain shifting models and one of
the ways that might might be useful for
helping people think about climate
mitigation would be instead of giving
them a temporal endpoint and saying this
is the you know given the the degree of
emissions here's the what we are
expecting
would it would it be possible with the
current climate
mechanisms the tools you have available
would it be possible to instead say
here's what we would expect with one
degree above what we have now and here's
what we would expect at two degrees of
what we have now because that would be
really helpful for
saying here's why we want to try to stop
to to do all this aggressive climate
medication does that make sense it does
um
yeah
my gut reaction is
that would be
that would be tough to do with the model
because right the the two degrees is
what the model is so I mean you can use
model A and it might be two degrees
warmer in let's say 2050 and model B
might be two degrees warmer in 20 30 and
you know 2030 or 2070 or whatever so you
have that kind of mismatch is that I
mean
I've seen people
um again but where I have seen people do
that we actually did that in some cases
with our Apple risk where right we're
basically modeling Apple risk really
just based on the distribution of
temperature so we could say yep if the
temperature got two degrees warmer so we
shifted over this distribution
statistically and change the variance
right we could do that
then then you could do that so that
would be a different approach to things
but I would think you would have to do
it statistically that that makes sense
that's exactly what we did with those
with those apple results that's not
that's not climate models we were just
if it got one degree warmer if it got
two degrees warmer if if the variance
increased by 10 or decreased by 10 what
would we get and and then kind of say
yep two degrees warmer is similar to
what the models are going to say in
2014.
I have I have a last
the other question also to me just a
quick one a comment on I'm always amazed
when they're showing whether uh you know
and projected weather and they talk
about the European model versus Vegeta
what's the big difference and why can't
folks get together and just
mesh them together and just from I'm
reading
I just just you know look at the news on
the web and you know why people can't
get together right so I'll leave it at
that I think there is a certain amount
of actually of nationalism and and kind
of competitiveness and things like that
but increasingly all the big
meteorological I mean it it the the the
the European model seems to get a big
thumbs up and we have these Big East
coasts it definitely does you know there
is a bias it happens to be better at but
I mean I can see there are many many
cases where it ain't the best model
tomorrow it ain't going to be the best
model
I have a question I would like to ask
you to uh forecast on the forecast and
maybe you don't have the answer my
question is
um what do you think will be the
Improvement on the forecast what would
be the nature of it would it be better
accuracy or a longer forecast in the
future and where will that Improvement
come from
according to your experience or maybe it
was I think where the next kind of
improvement step is is kind of in a
longer forecast a forecast in somewhere
between like
14 days and third and some days that
kind of three to four week period that
seems to be where a lot of the effort is
going I would say on the short term
I don't want to say we've done
everything already yeah I mean if yeah
if you got more observations and things
like that yeah you'd probably get some
improvements and things like that in in
that short period but I really think um
I really think you'll see some stuff
going on there in that Medium period um
a lot of neat stuff coming out with
machine learning and artificial
intelligence and things like that in
that kind of
thank you very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu